salami slicing tactics it's not a method
for cutting deli meats it's a military
strategy that China has used in the
South China Sea
this salami represents the sea each
slice is a portion of the region that
China has claimed over decades often
angering its neighbors who hold
competing claims and the U.S missed the
moment to intervene in part because it
was focused on working with China to
mediate other Global issues in North
Korea and Iran in that time China
occupied various coral reefs and in some
cases turned them into artificial
Islands today it controls 27 outposts
across the sea largely in disputed areas
which is why this mostly chopped up
salami represents the state of the sea
now that the U.S has taken a more
critical stance against China
so what is it doing to counter Beijing
the South China Sea is Central to the
indo-pacific where sixty percent of the
world's population lives trillions of
dollars worth of trade passes through
the sea each year according to the China
power project by the center for
strategic and International Studies
one-third of all global trade transits
the sea making many countries
economically dependent on the region
critical to the US economy because
America Imports around 90 percent of its
Advanced microchips from Taiwan
and roughly 14 percent of American
Maritime trade transited the sea in
2016. but in that same year over 64
percent of China's Maritime trade passed
through
874 billion dollars China is the largest
exporter of goods in the region and
having control over more of the sea
would potentially give the PRC a lot of
power over the economies of the U.S and
all of China's neighbors it is because
National Security is no longer simply
about territorial defense Economic
Security is National Security and that's
why the disputes in the region often
focus on one big jargony term
exclusive economic zones
eezs are areas in the sea where country
has jurisdiction over the resources they
generally extend around 200 nautical
miles
[Applause]
and because countries like Vietnam and
the Philippines rely on access to these
areas China's encroachment has posed a
problem for their security and economies
so you hear the fishermen complaining of
Chinese aggressive action and denying
them
the ability to fish in our own exclusive
economic zone in our own Waters
China says it has historical claims to
almost the entire South China Sea based
on a map from 1947 that illustrates
dashes coming through the majority of
the sea fittingly it's called the
nine-dash line but that line cuts
through eez claims for five other
countries to try and solidify its claim
to the Sea China has been incrementally
occupying various Islands to slowly
change the status quo AKA salami slicing
it began this process in the 1970s when
it took control of the Paracel Islands
from Vietnam
in 1995 China occupied Mischief Reef
which was claimed by the Philippines and
Vietnam
and in 2012 it took Scarborough Shoal
just 120 nautical miles west of the
Philippine island of Luzon then China
started to build on the islands which
concerned the US and prompted president
Xi Jinping to make this assurance in
2015.
we are committed to maintaining peace
and stability in the South China Sea and
China does not intend to pursue
militarization not long after the U.S
says the PRC broke its promise China now
has 20 outposts in the Paracel Islands
and seven in the spratleys several of
which have aircraft hangars missiles
military jamming equipment and other
Advanced systems throughout this process
some U.S officials expressed concern
they said they repeatedly told the
Chinese they were making a mistake
driving countries in the region closer
to the U.S militarily and hurting
China's ties with Washington
and in 2016 something critical happened
the Philippines brought China to an
international tribunal over its
occupation of Filipino territories
and the Philippines won the Hague said
that China's claims are illegal and all
the islands it had built would not
expand its exclusive economic zone but
China boycotted the tribunal and refused
to recognize the ruling
the U.S has taken steps to counter China
in two ways boosting its military
presence and strengthening diplomatic
relationships
America and the Philippines have been
Mutual defense allies since 1951 which
means if either countries attacked the
other must come to its Aid
in 2014 the U.S and the Philippines
signed the enhanced defense cooperation
agreement the Edgar gave America access
to five military bases in the
Philippines where the U.S can build
infrastructure and rotate troops however
the two countries relations have
teetered over the years the previous
president of the Philippines Rodrigo
duterte briefly strengthened
relationships with China which in turn
weakened the Philippines ties to the U.S
but the shift was short-lived and by
2021 the Philippines changed course this
year edca expanded to include four more
bases where the two countries ran their
largest military trails in decades if
it's an issue for the Philippines
in terms of international relations
it's an issue for the United States
because we're a mutual defense treaty
partner and we will come to the aid of
the Philippines if they're attacked and
I think it's as simple as that in
response to this growing cooperation
China's foreign Ministry spokesperson
Mao ning said it would escalate tensions
and endanger peace and stability in the
region well there's a superpower
struggle there is the geopolitical
competition U.S and China but China is
violating our sovereignty and Sovereign
rights and regardless of there is a
competition we have an issue in China in
that respect
U.S also regularly conducts freedom of
navigation operations in the South China
Sea phonops are meant to challenge
China's claims in the sea by
demonstrating that the United States
will fly sail and operate wherever
international law allows the PRC calls
these phonops illegal still the U.S has
strengthened its relationships with
other nearby Nations and encouraged some
to run patrols through the sea as well
in a recent call with General Secretary
Nuen futrong of Vietnam he and Biden
discussed how to maintain a free and
open indo-pacific China and Vietnam have
long held diplomatic relations and
Vietnam's economy relies on this
relationship but like the Philippines
Vietnam has also faced difficulties
operating in its own exclusive economic
zone due to China's encroachment and
harassment this gave the U.S an
opportunity to strengthen its ties with
yet another country in the South China
Sea we greatly value the relation ships
we have with all of these countries in
the region and there's one constant
among all of them and that is we respect
their sovereignty and that's where the
PRC I believe is missing the mark
because they want to operate on their
own set of rules and not respect the
sovereignty of the other existing
nations in the region
foreign